Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
Sorry, I'm a little bit late today.
Um, I couldn't... I couldn't, like, turn on my third monitor.
Because I forgot to... Um, for those who didn't know, during yesterday's stream, when I was trying to fix my game capture, one of my solutions was to literally unplug my third monitor.
Because sometimes, like, I can't get a fourth monitor.
I was like, oh, maybe it's because it's a monitor issue, where I can't have a fourth thing running if I have my third monitor on.
So that's why I was like, oh, maybe if I just... Maybe if I just turn off... Maybe I'll just unplug my third monitor.
Everything will work.
But it didn't work.
Anyway, because of that, I never plugged it back until today.
And I was trying to... For some reason, it didn't... It wasn't working at first, because I forgot...
I was like, oh, maybe if I disconnect the monitor... Um, if I just disconnect the monitor with my display settings, it will work.
And because of that, I forgot to reconnect my third monitor on my PC, because I had everything plugged, and I was like, wait a minute, why isn't it working?
And I was like, oh my god, I forgot to connect the display back to my actual PC with my programs!
But, yeah, anyway, so I was struggling to get that work.
I even was like, do I restart my PC again?
You know, after restarting it, like, six times, do I restart it?
Do I restart it again?
Like, but it's working now!
It's working now.
I need to replace this monitor.
I need to replace my third monitor.
My third monitor was not meant to be used as a third monitor!
It was not meant to be used as a vertical monitor, because it's so fucking heavy.
Um, but anyway, sorry, that's why, that's why, uh, I know I've been saying I should replace it for, like, months, now.
The only reason why I haven't is because I'm lazy.
I'm lazy, and I have to do all of this by myself, and I don't really want to do all of this.
Um, because my arms are noodle arms, and trying to plug this third monitor onto my setup was not fun at all.
Uh,
yeah, my vertical monitor is too fancy to be a vertical monitor.
It has to be a main monitor, but, like, but to make it a main monitor, I have to rearrange all my other monitors, and I can't, I can't, man, I can't do that.
Um, I, I, I, I, I don't want to do that.
Um, um, anyway, as I was, as I, um, was saying, um, welcome, welcome to the stream.
We are going to be playing Gold Gold Adventure Gold.
Um, it is, uh, created by an indie studio named Can Can Can, I know, I like, like, the, the naming mechanism with these games, um, but it was made by an indie studio called Can Can Can A Man, uh, who made Gold Gold Adventure Gold.
Um, but from what I could tell, it is a strategy game, um, and a lot of the assets are hand-drawn, um, are hand-drawn animated and everything, so, uh, so it's gonna be interesting to see.
So, it's apparently a god-like strategy game where the main objective is to make gold.
Um, I don't know if you guys could tell, uh, I don't, I don't know if you guys could tell.
Um, but yeah, it seems, it seems really interesting.
I can't wait to check it out.
Alright, I'm booting the game for the first time, by the way, I'm going in blind.
I figure that's, like, the best, um, the best way to, you know, uh, in, um, engage in these types of games, is to just go in blind and learn, learn the game as we go along.
Alright.
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
Alright, Gold Gold Adventure Gold.
Ooh, English, please.
Ooh, there's my god hand.
Oh my god, there's my evil god hand.
Ha ha ha ha.
Uh, yes.
Oh, oh, it booted me.
I was like, where did it take me?
But then it was like, uh, would I like to collect?
Do you understand?
No.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
You gotta buy my data from Google first.
Ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha.
Uh, no screen shake, please.
Uh, I'm just gonna make sure it's everything I want.
Oh wait, there's pet tools.
Oh my god, I get to have a pet?
Nice.
Um...
Always the correct answer.
The sound and dust...
Yes, I'd like that, please, when I tap out.
Um...
Oh my god, they're saying Gold Gold Adventure Gold.
Alright.
Wave defense.
Okay, I should learn how to play this game.
Oh, the art's really cute.
Alright.
Gold Adventure Gold.
Moving my camera first.
Okay.
Use your mouse wheel or button.
Zoom in or zoom out.
Okay.
Alright.
Press space to pause and unpause.
Okay, I can stop time.
You will receive three perk points.
Allow you to unlock buildings, spells, upgrades, and other abilities we have given you.
Alright.
So that you're...
Starting perk.
Oh, these are my perks.
Alright.
Eat my...
Eat my key.
Recruit a spearman.
How can I get this game?
Oh yeah!
If you see the link...
Thank you, Smokey, for the amazing segue.
Uh, thank you to the super chat.
Thank you.
But if you click on the link pinned in my chat, um, or in my description, um, you can wishlist the game or buy it.
Try it out right now.
For yourself.
Well, my first recruitment settlement.
Okay, like...
Oh, it's this.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
I haven't played an RTS game in so fucking long.
Alright, and there they go.
There they go.
We already know how this is going to end, Doki and Strata game.
Hey, I used to play RTS game all the time, okay?
You haven't seen me, uh, unlock my third eye yet, okay?
This is your pet.
Oh, it's my pet!
What does he do?
Don't worry, you're god.
Oh, he protects me!
Okay, do your thing.
Wait, is that the enemy?
Oh, it is.
Oh my god, look at him go.
You got this.
How do I name you?
Alright, Dragoon.
Wait, I should be dad.
Dad, what the f- No.
Dad.
There you go.
I was like, wait a minute.
Alright, he did it!
Yippee!
Oh, check the audio?
Oh, bring a little bit.
Alright, let me open- Let me do that real quick.
Audio.
There you go.
That should be fine.
Alright.
There you go.
Go mix my thing.
Oh, this artwork is so cute, though.
I really like the artwork.
Click to open the godbeast lair.
Hello.
Hello there.
Select one of the recent behaviors to encourage or discourage.
Oh, so he can build.
He can gather.
He can loot.
Bring prey.
What the f- What the f- Oh, I can pet him.
Hello, little guy.
Hello, dad.
Hello.
Yeah, dad went to the dog sitter.
I'm like, I...
I have a new...
I have a new dad now.
You can pet him.
10 out of 10.
As done.
Now you can reward.
I already did.
Oh, wait.
I can, like, brush him, too.
And then, what's this?
Oh, it's like those, like, scratcher things.
Alright, what's this?
Bad!
Bad dad!
And then I'll give, like, positive reinforcements and balance it out with negative reinforcements, too.
Just so he's, like...
Just so I can increase the Stockholm Syndrome more.
Bad!
That's right!
You don't know what you did wrong, did you?
You'll never know.
So you'll try so hard and please me because you'll never know what...
What is the bad thing you did?
Don't worry.
I'll love-bomb you right now.
I'll...
That's good.
Keep him on the edge.
Please stop being evil.
Now your first building is finished.
It's time to recruit your first spearman.
Alright.
Oh, that's the warrior haul.
Recruit.
Uh...
Oh my god, he looks like...
He's a monk.
He looks like a monkey.
Is that a monkey?
Okay.
Burn and unable to reach the Shining Status of Moth Knight.
Those who return...
Survive often.
Alright.
I'll recruit you.
I did it.
You need to take time to get recruited.
Okay.
New work?
Don't wait up.
Hello.
Use to select the quest.
Explore quest.
Fear quest.
Defend quest.
Okay, explore.
Go do your thing.
Alright.
Let's go.
Time to love bomb him a little...
Paying tax...
Wait.
What did he ever say?
Paying?
Wait.
Has this...
No.
There you go.
Paying taxes.
Alright.
This is your job now.
Make sure everybody pay their taxes.
Alright?
If you don't...
That's right.
Everyone has to pay their taxes.
Let him know.
He has to pay his taxes.
Okay.
You haven't been good for too long.
Now, yeah.
That's why.
You think he lives here for free?
As your crew...
Farmhouse is being spawning around the map.
They grow over time.
Gardening more and more gold, which can be taxed.
Which can then be taxed.
You can build them manually, so be sure to protect them.
Right click on the border checkpoint to assign the attack quest.
Wait.
Right click?
Oh, there you go.
Yeah.
Attack that.
Now, attack quest in place.
Adventures will now attempt to destroy the target.
Alright.
Cool.
Wait.
Where's dad?
Is he trying to collect taxes?
Did he do it?
Alright.
Alright, dad.
It's time.
Go.
Attack it.
Come on, dad.
After you finish collecting taxes.
It's time.
We love gold.
Give me the gold.
Give Doki the gold.
Here's my dragon tax.
Doki plus.
That's right.
You live at Doki land and you're not paying taxes?
Time to get evicted.
Wait.
What's this?
Is he going to love me unconditionally, right?
He'll be fine.
That's right.
My tax collector dog.
Don't make me angry.
I'll send dad over.
You're...
All right.
It's almost down.
Almost there.
Come on.
Just a little bit more.
Yay!
That's right.
Kill him.
Make sure none of his family or his lineage survive.
Not in Doki land.
If you don't pay taxes, I'll just wipe you from existence.
A lot of new land, which means more opportunities and more chances for adventurers to grow stronger.
Strong adventurers are important for the survival of your city.
Oh, hey.
You got something.
What the...
Did he just collect his tax?
All right.
Right-click to assign the exploration.
Okay.
Explore this.
Ventures are filled with both gold.
Experience outbreaks every night so you can reduce your strength regularly by sending...
Okay.
I'm going to recruit more...
More guys.
At this point.
Get another guy.
He needs a friend.
And they can be like, I don't know, good roommates or something.
That's right.
Get in there.
Pavel.
Pavel, get over there.
Wait.
Uh...
Pavel, no.
Get over here.
Pavel!
Oh, wait.
He did it.
Okay, Tana, never mind.
We didn't need you.
I'm looking out for number one.
Now they...
Let's embark on a dungeon.
Expeditions are harder.
More...
They usually require a strong group.
Okay.
Where is this?
Click on the...
Oh, there it is.
Click to browse the expedition.
Click here.
Click where?
They're not...
Oh, here!
I was like...
Am I not clicking it?
Alright.
Tanner and Pavel, we're gonna start your...
We're gonna start your meet cute moment right here.
The moment that will change your lives forever.
Alright.
There we go.
Wait, I can...
No, I can't send Dad.
Dad's just here to collect taxes and beat up anything that's in front of him.
Alright.
Now, let's embark on a...
Oh, they're traveling over.
Okay.
Dad's collecting my taxes as he should be.
Farmhouse, income...
Wait, this...
This farmhouse doesn't make me any money.
She's a cow, right?
We should eat her.
If you don't make money for me, you might as well feed...
Feed the kingdom in other ways.
Or else...
That's right.
It's not cat...
It's not like inhumane because she's not human.
Turn her into a grade A steak.
Exactly.
Alright, what is he doing?
Are you collecting...
You're not...
Go back to collecting taxes.
No!
Make sure everybody is paying taxes.
That's right.
That's your only job.
Oh, I can cruise to speed.
Alright.
Boy, Tom, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Anything else I could build?
Oh, it's just a warrior holo.
What's this?
I don't...
I haven't unlocked it yet.
Are they okay?
Do you think they'll...
They'll live, right?
There's two of them in there.
They'll be okay.
I think?
Yeah, see?
They're literally...
They're fine.
All right.
Where is...
Where's dad?
All right.
Let's see.
Okay, good.
Good job.
You're doing...
Good job, dad.
You're doing a good job.
You know what?
Go loot some treasures.
Go do your thing.
Get me some gold.
I demand some gold.
Dungeons grew progressively stronger.
Even if the dungeon was suppressed, it may be a good idea to hire more spearmen.
All right.
Might as well.
Oh, I only have two.
All right.
Choose a new ability?
Oh.
I can't even choose.
Oh, there it is.
Burn your enemies just by looking at them.
Your units regenerate faster when you are looking at them.
I don't need to regenerate.
I'll just hire new people.
More damage.
It's fine.
It's not inhumane because she's not human.
Dookie the bird.
George, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Madis, thank you for the super chat.
Here's my dookie tax.
Can I get you to sing me a happy birthday for not committing dookie tax evasion?
Of course, Madis.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Madduff.
Yay.
Pay your taxes.
But only the Doki tax.
All the other taxes don't really matter.
Treasure from Trevor.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Tax is paid.
Get Dad a nice bag of treats and have a lovely day.
Thank you for the Akasupa, Trevor.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, Howard, even while simply looking at it will make them stronger.
Ooh, they just like to be looked at, I see.
Alright, cool.
Your final tool in keeping your city standing, place the defense quest on anything you want to defend it.
Once someone claims a bounty, its reward will slowly drain them away.
The adventurers will patrol the defense quest vicinity until it runs dry.
Oh, okay.
Defense quest.
Oh, here, okay.
Well, obviously we'll defend here.
Because, like... Wait, who the fuck is Whiskers?
No matter the... You should be able to face...
Who is Whiskers?
Oh, I'm looking at them.
That's right.
I'm looking at you.
What are you gonna do?
Oh my god, my crops!
No!
Don't worry, I'm looking at him.
Don't worry.
No!
Who would feed them?
Oh my god.
Defend here.
No!
I don't understand!
I'm looking at him!
I...
Yay, I did it!
Not the crops!
Alright.
Okay, now...
Continue game.
Is this the tutorial?
Or...
Move...
Oh, wait.
Oh, it...
Wait, what?
Is this new?
Oh no, this is new.
I was like, who...
Okay, this is new.
Oh, this is old.
Sorry.
This is old.
Okay, new game.
Survive six days.
Or in this dungeon will only spawn if waves.
Neglected scent.
I feel like I'm ready for famine.
Now famine is all British.
Don't worry.
We have all the cow ladies we can eat.
Guys, don't worry.
Immortal being of legend.
Presumed extinct.
Where the rock with face painted on it.
Alright, guys.
Who should we get as our pet?
A little...
Immortal being of...
A little immortal being or a rock?
But Doki has a funny face painted on it.
We get the...
The literal immortal being.
You wanna learn a basis before you start?
No.
Alright, I feel like I've learned enough.
Alright.
Dad.
I'm pretty sure...
Oh, I can rename all of them.
Um...
Karen.
Alright.
Our name...
Dragoon.
Alright.
Let's do this.
Fence.
Oh my god.
I can build a fence?
I can build a forge?
Do I have enough gold for that?
I can build a market?
I don't think I have enough...
Gold.
Wait, no.
I do.
Inn.
I'll build a forge first.
Alright.
And then I'll do an inn.
Um...
Adam, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Finally, I'm not on night shift.
So I can watch my Oshi live.
I waited so long.
Thank you for the super chat, Adam.
Thank you.
What's this?
Oh, it's a border checkpoint.
Where's dad?
Alright, dad.
Get over there.
Attack this.
That's right.
We need the land so we can expand.
Alright.
We have Dragoon and...
Wait, who's this guy?
Who's she?
Oh, is this for the forge?
Oh, it's so cute.
Look at this little guy.
He's just...
Just blowing on it.
These are your goals.
Completing them gives you perks.
Okay, destroying that.
Alright.
We gotta get a perk real quick.
Rangers Guild.
Gobble.
Hideout.
Warrior Hall.
Wait.
I can be a gob...
If...
If we get goblins...
We can get gold.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha.
Recruit holy mooligans to smite your foes.
Oh my god.
More cow ladies, please.
We can go gobble mode.
Exactly.
Going out with a blast.
Adventures with mana explode on death.
Dealing two extra manas.
Your adventures deal six plus.
And gain more gold.
But you gotta always get more gold.
Holy cow lady.
You know what?
Let's get the moon...
What's got?
The moonistry?
Alright.
Let's get the moonistry in here.
The moonistry.
And then...
What else?
Do we get?
Wait.
Where's my gobble?
Oh, there we go.
Gobble hideout.
That's right.
And then gobble hideout too.
Let's get our moonistry in here.
Uh...
In farmhouse.
Can I do anything?
With my farmhouse?
What can they do?
Select perks.
Perks encyclopedia.
Construct new roads.
Wait.
I can make roads?
That's fine.
They don't need a road.
Let's just go to your god beast.
Toggle structure clipping.
Okay, he's still...
He's still doing his thing.
Oh, apparently...
Apparently...
Is it her that's voiced by...
Oh!
Apparently, the Mooladin...
This is Lily Pichu.
Apparently.
That's her.
The...
I shouldn't say that, but...
I shouldn't say that to Lily.
Okay.
The first thing in my head was that...
The big city...
It's Lily...
That's just...
Lily Pichu.
Let's call her Lily...
There you go.
Oh, wait.
Who the heck is Kaja?
Who's she...
Oh!
She's from the...
She's the Gobbles!
Alright.
Nice.
Wait.
Have you started collecting your taxes yet?
No.
Seriously?
Yay!
Go, Lily!
Okay.
And then...
Kaja will be...
Max...
All right.
Let's see.
The Munistry.
Are you making any...
Income for me?
No, you're not.
Okay.
There's the Gobble Hideout.
Can I get...
Recruit at least four units.
It's the Tax Man here.
I need to collect my taxes soon.
I...
Oh, wait.
Oh, my God.
She's collecting...
That's right.
Taxed them silver.
Make sure they know what's good for them.
All right.
You earned...
Yes.
I want to redeem my reward.
The Tax Man is coming.
Gain more experience.
Vaults of Lightning fall.
The more spells you have cast, the more casting your spell costs.
Gain more experience from...
Okay.
Let's get less gold from that.
God.
I love...
That's right.
The Rat Man is here.
He's always watching you.
He's always here to collect the taxes.
Um...
How do I...
How do I access the Forge?
Oh, there it is.
Dwellers.
Oh, hey, look.
Max Mofo is inside.
There's daggers for...
Oh, do I have enough...
Oh, I have so much money.
We'll upgrade that, actually.
Uh...
Why are you so confused, Dad?
Why are you so confused?
Pay your taxes.
Stop being confused and get the taxes in.
But don't worry.
I'll love bomb you so you'll stay with me forever.
That's right.
Uh...
Let's see.
Is anyone already doing it?
Pelvis red.
That's so messed up.
Like, what can I build?
And that's everything.
Oh, I should build a market.
Claiming that whole...
Oh, it passively generates gold.
I like that.
We'll put it here.
Alright.
Oh, there's the farm.
Don't worry.
Silver is here to collect more taxes.
Let's recruit more cow ladies.
I can recruit two.
Am I recruiting?
Do I have enough?
She vows to protect this.
Wait.
Why can I get another one?
I don't understand.
Why can I have more than one cow lady?
I can have more...
Oh, I can't even have more goblins?
Wait.
Did I max it up?
Recruit one out of three.
Oh, I must have need...
Do I need more inns or something?
I might need another inn.
Maybe.
I'll construct another inn just in case.
Uh.
Oh.
Increaser.
Allows place for relax.
No.
Wait.
Am I keeping them satisfied?
What do you mean?
I have an inn?
I have a farmhouse.
And I have a market.
What else do they need?
Oh.
Destroy a catacomb.
Is there any dungeons nearby?
Okay, let's just attack this, actually.
I don't know if there's any...
Yeah, there's no dungeons near me right now.
Wait.
Who the heck is Stitches?
Who's living next to my house?
Wally?
Who lives here?
This is my land!
Wait.
What the f...
Who's...
Who is my neighboring?
Who are my neighbors?
I gotta get them out of here.
How dare they?
Wait.
I'm gonna...
Whatever.
They can...
They can do that.
Who are my neighbors?
How dare they be next to me?
This is my land.
I can't see them.
Okay.
Yeah, this is true.
But not enough money?
Is that it?
Are they very expensive?
Are my cow ladies very expensive?
Alright, Maximofo.
What are you gonna do?
Good.
You explored.
Wow.
I gave him money and...
He took that and just left.
Okay.
He got his gold and he's happy.
He's fine.
He's fine with that.
I'm like...
That's all you're gonna explore?
Job's done.
Job done.
Alright.
Go, Lily.
Go.
Beat him up.
That's right.
You got this, Lily.
Did that leave her?
That's like...
Job done.
There's more to this, Dad.
Dad just literally left Lily.
She'll be fine.
I mean, she is pretty strong, though.
Oh my god.
Look at her go.
She's very strong.
Oh my god.
Alright.
You unlock this chest for me?
What's in it?
Oh, I'll never know, I guess.
Uh...
Well, I'm slowly, passively collecting my...
Who the fuck is Wally?
And what is he doing on my land?
Someone get Wally out of here.
I wonder if I have to build more.
I want to build an inn just to test the stereo.
Let's see.
Forge.
Um...
Yeah, I'm going to build another inn just to test the stereo.
See if I can...
Bro is doing some tax evasion.
You cannot evade the rat.
The rat is always watching.
Alright.
Uh...
Tax Wally.
Yeah.
If he's on my land, I should be allowed to tax him.
That's right.
Kill Wally.
Can I rename Wally?
Like, I'm just going to rename this guy, too.
That's right.
Oh my god.
He's coming over.
That's right.
Get Wally out of here.
Oh my god.
Wally's trying to kill Max's house.
Get him.
Get him, Max!
Alright.
That's fine.
Oh, I knew it.
I...
Wait, no.
Actually, it doesn't work like that.
Wait, what?
It's okay.
Dad's here to help, too.
Oh, wait.
What is he doing with that...
With his head?
Oh my god.
That's this man's head.
No taxation without representation.
That's right.
You see that, Dragoons?
That's what's going to happen to you.
Don't pay your taxes.
I'm going to make your skull into a nice...
Nice cup.
Don't attack their home, too.
Actually, no.
Maybe don't.
Actually...
How do I get rid of this?
Oh, maybe don't.
Oh my god.
Okay, maybe...
Okay, Lily might die.
Oh, Lily's gonna die.
How do I...
There we go.
Lily, leave.
Oh...
Wait, Dad.
She'll be fine, right?
She's fine.
Look, she's fine.
Dad will be okay, too.
I believe.
She...
And there's that legendary immortal.
So she should be fine.
I believe.
Okay, we might need more people.
Can't recruit, though.
I don't know why.
Yeah, maybe a 1v3 was not it.
It's okay.
Look, see?
Everything's fine.
Everything is okay.
How do I get rid of the spear thing, though?
Oh, it's...
Oh, it says 10 seconds.
Okay.
Well...
Goodbye, Max.
Wave incoming?
Wait.
Wait, I'm not ready.
Oh, I got another goblin!
Wait, how did I get you?
Oh my god, I got another goblin!
Wait, how do I get another one?
Oh, I got two...
Two cow ladies, too!
Okay, I'm ready.
I'm ready for this.
That's it.
I'm ready.
I don't know how that happened, but I'm ready.
Oh.
Oh, Dad.
That's going in by himself.
Dad, no.
Dad, that's a bad idea.
That is a very bad idea.
He's like, okay.
Like, okay.
I'll stop.
How do I get duration?
Maybe like that?
I want to, like...
Get the fear thing out.
Uh...
You know what?
I think we can...
Start the fight, right?
I think everybody's ready.
Right?
I have enough.
Should be fine.
Should be okay.
And I'm, like...
Passively generating income, too.
Dwellers.
Completed.
All defeated enemies drop.
Oh.
Income.
Improves income for all farms.
I like that.
Alright.
More gold.
More gold for me.
If I can recruit one more...
Oh, I guess they, like, passed.
I can...
I have to wait now?
Maybe?
I'm pretty sure.
I should name them to get attached.
You're right.
I'll name them after you guys.
Uh...
Who gave me that idea?
They can't be replaced.
You're right, Jordan.
You're now a big titty cat lady.
Alright.
This is fine.
Where's dad?
Dad?
Dad, get over here.
Why...
Why are you depressed?
Dad fled from danger.
Dad saw Gouda and their face deserve prepared...
Wait.
What made you depressed?
I don't understand.
Why are you depressed?
Why?
Don't be depressed.
Here.
Is it because you're paying...
Okay.
Here.
Buy a beer.
Buy...
If you're...
If you're depressed...
Here.
Buy a beer.
Everything will be okay.
Just drink away your problems.
It's okay.
I hate that.
On to greater pastors.
Wait.
Why is he depressed?
Everybody else is happy.
I don't...
What happened?
Thirsty?
Wait.
You're...
Euphoric.
You're depressed too?
What did you...
You really were just a boy.
How are you depressed?
You were just a boy.
For pure talk.
Don't make him an alcoholic.
Alcoholic.
Blackfire.
Thank you for the five gifted chips.
Thank you.
I don't understand.
Why are you depressed?
I did so much.
You were just born.
Here you go.
Can't be depressed when I'm scratching you.
That's right.
Yeah.
You can't be depressed.
Look.
Look at all the love I was giving you.
Alright.
It's fine.
Everything is...
Oh, I need more perks.
What did I get?
Kills nearby creatures.
Recruit spearmen.
Oh, we should get that, actually.
And then we'll build a well.
And...
We'll put it...
We'll put it here.
Alright, dragoons.
Build that.
And then if I...
After I kill the catacomb, I should get another quest.
Yeah.
Wait, I fell in 36 hours?
Build 16...
Structures?
Wait, it's been 33.
It's been 33 hours.
How do I build 36...
16...
Stru...
How...
Okay.
I lost a chance to hit twice.
I have a chance to hit...
Oh, I just got...
Summons a pair of wolves to your aid.
We'll do...
This one.
Um...
Is there anything cool around here?
Yeah, it's everything, right?
You know what?
Kill this guy.
Dude.
Just for the sake of it.
Just kill him.
Doesn't deserve to live.
That's right.
Fuck that guy in particular as well.
Uh...
Wait.
Wait, what...
What is that?
Wait, what the...
No, my taxman!
Someone save my taxman!
How...
No!
Get...
Run!
Oh, my God.
I...
Let...
Run!
Oh, my God.
Get in there!
Save the taxman!
We'll never be able to tax...
Tax!
No!
My crops!
Oh, my God.
My crops.
Okay.
We gotta get that.
And then we gotta get that.
And then...
Oh, this is bad.
Oh, no.
This is so bad.
Where are my others?
Where are my men?
Where are my goblins?
Wait.
Oh, my God.
Where is everything?
Please.
Someone save my farm.
Protect the cow women.
If anything.
They are the most important thing.
Oh, my God.
I was not paying attention.
Okay.
Wait.
We gotta build another...
We gotta build another moon story soon.
Don't worry.
It's fine.
We'll build another...
No!
Who the fuck is Jordan?
Oh, wait.
Oh, yeah.
I forgot.
Wait.
Is dad still alive?
Oh, dad's still alive.
Okay.
That's fine.
Dad's dealing with this.
Oh, my God.
There's so many...
So much death.
It's okay.
The tax man is still alive.
I...
I was not...
I was not paying attention.
I was too busy getting gold.
Oh, my God.
No, not the crops.
No.
My farm.
I was too busy getting gold.
Oh, wait.
Jordan's back, guys.
Look at that.
He's okay.
It was just a flesh wound.
He's okay, guys.
He's okay.
All right.
It's fine.
Everything is okay.
We just gotta attack.
It's okay.
Everything is okay.
We got another...
We got another moon story.
It's fine.
We'll build another fountain, too.
Just in case.
Wait.
Do I have room for...
Yeah.
We'll build a fountain here, too.
And then...
Oh, my God.
So much death.
Cow lady.
No.
We still have...
Wait.
Oh, my cow lady.
No.
We still have...
We still have our cow lady.
See?
She's still here.
Lily's still alive.
Look.
See?
And Jordan, too.
You're okay.
You didn't die.
I have more goblins?
I'd like more goblins, please.
All right.
See?
Everything is fine.
There's nothing to worry.
See?
Our...
Our moon story is back.
Let's just make another one.
I feel like the cows are really strong in general.
Uh...
Wait.
How do I fix this?
Oh, rebuild.
Okay.
We'll rebuild your home.
Wait.
Can I promote her?
Let's get moving.
How do I promote her?
Steadfast.
I don't think I can.
Wait.
She's a healer?
Oh, my gosh.
She is not DPS.
I...
I just...
I just noticed she is not DPS.
Uh...
All right.
See, guys?
We did it.
I brought the mirror.
I don't understand how to...
Guys, you know how...
Uh...
Wait.
What?
What do you mean wave incoming?
Oh, my God.
Jordan.
Jordan, you fucking idiot.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
We gotta defend here.
That's all they're coming from, right?
Yeah.
That's the only way they're coming.
Oh, my God.
And we have to defend here.
Okay.
I should have built more goblins.
I'm gonna go build more goblins right now.
I'm...
I'm gonna build more goblins right now.
It's fine.
Oh, my God.
No.
They're destroying their homes again.
We gotta protect them.
Okay, I see him.
I see the tarantulas, the vile.
But it's okay.
It's only... It's okay.
Everybody's defending.
See, we have a heal circle, too.
I require more goblins.
We need more goblins.
What else can I build?
I feel like there's nothing else to really build other than, like, upgrades and stuff.
Produce daggers.
Produce dark swords for heretic mouladans.
Alright, you know what?
Fuck it.
I don't have... I don't have the perk for spearmen.
Because I didn't care much about it.
Faults fall over.
The more spells you cast, the more power.
Summon a pair of wolves.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Let's get some wolves in here.
Wait, but how do I summon wolves?
Wait, one out of three?
What happened to my second cow... No, okay.
Yeah, I have three cow ladies now.
How do I get more?
Do you guys know how I get more goblins?
I feel like you guys might have read more than me.
I'm a little confused how to get more goblins.
Yeah, fuck it.
We're having wolves now.
Okay, defend.
So how do I delete the quest?
Oh, here.
Okay, well...
I mean, we'll just keep it there.
You build more of their structures.
Oh, thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
I can't read.
What do they want?
Just build another...
Oh, do they want more ends?
More...
More ends, maybe?
What would I need defenses for?
Oh my god, no!
Oh, my farm!
Okay.
That's fine.
It's fine.
We can...
We can rebuild.
It's fine.
We'll just...
We'll have our people starve a little bit.
And it'll be okay.
It'll be okay, you know?
A little bit of hunger doesn't hurt anybody.
We gotta...
Starve a little for...
Starve a little bit for...
For the city.
For the kingdom.
That's okay.
Sometimes you have to starve a little.
I wanna...
Do this dungeon.
Actually, we should attack this first.
For the greater good.
For the city.
Do you not care about the city?
That's the tax collector.
That's right.
Collect the taxes.
Alright, we should rename everybody.
Alright.
Disco.
Lily.
Annabelle.
Alright.
Afro.
I'm naming people randomly in chat.
Grass.
Oh, wait.
This should be me.
Jokey.
I'm the tax man.
That's right.
The builders can just be dragoon.
Dragoon too.
Oh, wait.
I can't...
Dragoons.
Dragoon.
Alright.
They're just all...
I'm the tax man.
Of course I'm the tax man.
Oh, now...
Oh, the more...
It is.
Basically, the more...
The more I'm expanding, the more I get...
Oh, nice.
Goal destroy.
Foul item.
Alright.
Good for them.
Uh...
What else should I build?
I don't...
I'll just build more inn.
A place for...
That's...
I'll let him...
Uh...
How do I do the dungeon again?
Depths...
Available...
Expectation...
Expedition...
Expeditions?
How do I...
Do the dungeons again?
I know they taught me.
I know they like...
Teach me.
But like...
Oh, explore quest.
Oh, is this?
Oh.
Okay.
Put us here, just in case.
My farmhouse.
We don't need fences.
It's fine.
Wait.
Someone heal this guy.
Dad, get over here.
Dad, my drag wounds need help.
Dad's like...
Yippee.
Look at the goblins.
Oh.
Look at this goblin house.
This town is so...
You live in it.
You can move out whenever you want.
But you know this is all you have.
But yet you still live in my depressing home.
So you mean we can't...
You can move whenever you want.
If he moves, we get less taxes.
How the fuck do I build these...
Okay.
That's fine.
We don't need fences where I come from.
I believe in the Doki town.
Alright.
Let's see.
Push door.
Go.
Go to the dungeon.
There's nothing else to do here.
I am not...
I mean...
Destroy the monstrous idol.
Where the fuck is that monstrous...
You know I'm building more cow ladies.
Fuck it.
Let's just build more cow ladies.
We need more.
The people demand more cow women.
And like, you know, if we're starving, we can just eat the cows.
They're practically the same thing as regular cows, if you think about it.
Wait, there's only one guy exploring it.
Is she okay?
Oh, she did it.
Nice.
On to greener pastures.
Let's get moving.
Alright.
Van-ta...
Van-na-ta...
Van-na...
Van-na-ski.
Okay, there you go.
That's your name now.
Wait, did I not...
Oh, I forgot to...
Van...
Oh, you have to...
Press enter.
Are they still Dragoon?
They are still Dragoon.
That's all I care about.
Alright, Lucy.
You're Allen now.
Wait, is that still depressed?
Oh, there you go.
He's euphoric now.
But why?
What's making him so happy?
I made friends with...
I made a friend with Dragoon!
Oh my god!
I had a beer!
I...
That's why he's happy.
He's like, yippee!
I got beer!
Yay!
Oh, shit!
Um...
Where are they coming from?
Oh my god!
No!
My farm!
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
They're coming over.
We can rebuild.
As always.
We can always rebuild.
They're only coming from the right.
Yeah?
Oh, they are.
Guys!
Oh my god!
No!
Not my farm!
Oh, hey!
Let's send people in here.
Let's get Max Mofo.
Let's get these guys.
Okay, maybe they should...
Alright.
Retrieve the Wand of Amorak.
It's fine.
We'll have...
Oh my god!
It's not fine.
It is not fine.
Guys, defend!
Guys!
My Fountain of Healing!
Oh my god!
Please!
Okay.
Rebuild.
We'll rebuild this.
We can always rebuild.
Please.
We literally...
There's only one way.
It's okay.
A little bit of...
Wait, there's a dungeon in the middle of my town?
Why is there...
Okay.
Why is there a dungeon in the middle of my town?
Like, where did that spawn from?
Alright.
Go in there.
Go and get that Wand of whatever.
Okay.
We rebuild that.
We can't have our farm back though, unfortunately.
Who...
Who fucking...
Why are my farms being made in the...
Edges of the border?
Like...
Why are they there?
I don't know.
Okay.
Maybe we'll have more goblins.
Maybe.
I'll have another goblin.
It doesn't hurt to have more goblins.
It doesn't hurt.
There's more goblins.
For the kingdom.
Oh, nice!
What perk do I have now?
Mana Explode on...
Yeah, fuck it.
At least like their deaths...
At least their...
It means something.
Do you think they'll be fine?
It is says level 22.
It should be fine.
Yay!
More goblins!
Wait.
What's that?
Oh my god.
There's this one guy.
Someone get this one guy out of here.
They'll be fine.
I believe in them.
Alright.
Well, I'm gonna wait until these guys are done with this dungeon.
Because they're like my strongest.
So I'm gonna wait for them to be done.
So...
Uh...
Destroy a monstrous idol.
Was that the monstrous idol that I did?
Oh yeah.
See, they're okay.
Oh my god.
There's like a story down there.
The manticore wars.
The party attacks.
Stealing 99 damage to the manticore.
They're having their own little fucking adventure right now.
Uh...
It's fine.
We'll just let these guys have a good time.
Wait.
Where's my...
I should heal her.
She should be fine.
I believe in Disco.
This is our first time fighting.
You go, Disco.
That's right, Disco.
You go.
You go, girl.
Okay, there's the farm.
I don't know what else to build.
Oh my god.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Where?
Oh my god.
They're all the way...
Wait.
It's just one guy.
I mean, I could defend it.
Oh my god.
No.
They're coming from the sewers.
Okay.
I didn't realize they were actually...
coming from the sewers.
Are they still...
Are they not done yet?
Okay.
There's still a lot of monsters.
He was bait.
They was bait all along.
They were...
They were in the sewers.
Okay.
I'll put...
Oh my god.
Please.
Please get them.
Not the crops.
We can't have another famine, guys.
We can't have another famine.
Please.
I just...
My best people are in this dungeon.
And they're still there.
Wait.
What?
Oh no.
What broke?
I should have...
Where are my people?
Where are they?
Why are they?
Excuse me.
Where are you guys not...
There's a rat here?
Excuse...
Please.
Stop.
Are you going to the...
I swear...
Oh my god.
He's like...
I'm too depressed.
I...
He's...
Please.
Someone killed Cheddar.
Our fucking farm.
Oh my thing.
Where are my...
Okay.
We're getting...
We're gonna...
Oh my god.
It's because they're patrolling this.
Get out of here.
Get...
Get out.
Get out of here.
You got your money.
Go...
They're like...
Why kill when I can get free money over here?
Oh my god.
Please.
Someone kill Cheddar.
Someone please.
He's just nomming on the cowhouse.
I did.
I did put a bounty.
But no one cares.
Someone please.
The fact that they were...
Oh my god.
They were literally staying there for the free money.
They're like...
Why?
Why work so hard when I can get free money right here?
That's so fucked up.
Defending is just easier.
Alright.
Into the dungeon.
Get in there.
Get in...
No one's like to be a man.
You're dealing.
The fact that...
Oh my god.
Assembling.
There's another raid?
Where did they assemble?
Where?
Where are they assembling?
Oh my god.
What is that?
Reward's too small.
Oh my god.
The reward is too small.
You're level four.
Disco is level 11.
And he's willing to do this.
Oh my god.
I can't believe I have to micromanage this.
I can't believe it.
Oh my...
Reward too fucking small.
You fuckers.
You...
You live in my town.
And...
And have the audacity to save reward too small.
Alright.
Burn your...
I'm just gonna start looking at them.
If...
I swear to god.
I'm just...
I'm just gonna start looking at them.
I'm almost like...
Disco doesn't know her price yet.
It's fine.
I'll do it myself.
I'll just look at them.
Power too though.
That's right.
Leave.
I'll do it myself.
I'm fucking...
Reward too small.
I...
Oh my god.
That's...
That's right.
Leave.
It's so...
If it...
Leave.
Get out of here.
Get out of my city.
That's right.
I'll just watch them while I figure this out.
Uh...
Do I need another...
Passively generating...
Gold generation.
A few tents claiming.
I feel like I can build another market.
Okay.
I'll build another one.
I mean...
More gold, right?
As long as I get more gold.
That's all that matters.
Oh my god.
I swear to god.
Where are they coming from?
Okay.
Right here.
Oh my god.
That's a lot.
Okay.
It's fine.
I'm looking at them.
And then I've got wolves too.
I've got the wolves in here.
That's right.
I've got the wolves.
The wolves will be here.
I swear to god.
If they feel like this job...
Where is my...
The rest of them?
Reward too small.
I'm getting attacked.
This is your home.
This is literally your home.
There's no such thing as reward too small.
This is where you live.
Oh my god.
I'm rebuilding.
Oh my...
That's right.
You fucking deserve this.
Oh my god.
You all deserve this.
I can't reward...
Where are...
Are they all eating?
Where...
Where are they?
Where are my people?
Oh wow.
Now that I put $300 down the line...
Down the line.
They're like...
Alright.
Sure.
I'll come over.
He's too cheap.
Alright.
Okay.
We need this.
We need the burning thing.
Alright.
What did I earn?
The rat king has been slain.
Thank fucking god.
We'll grab that.
Thank god.
It's stupid team.
Mine.
I should have hired the spearmen.
I feel like the spearmen...
The spearmen will actually do their jobs.
Instead of the shit that they're putting me through right now.
Alright.
Let's pick one of the...
Okay.
Improve all farms.
Alright.
Both the mayor and the arrow.
Oh!
I'm greedy!
I literally built this place for you to live in.
But oh...
I'm the greedy one.
The rats began to swarm.
Search the sewers for...
Are you...
Where...
What rats?
What?
Okay.
Let's get people in here.
We're not...
Alright.
There we go.
We'll get our best men in here.
I'm just like...
What do you mean the rats began to swarm?
Oh!
Too small!
Oh my god.
How about...
Yeah.
There we go.
At least Octavia knows what's good for her.
Alright.
Thank god.
She knows her worth.
They're in the walls.
That's it.
Get this quest out of here.
Fucking...
Leeches.
It's all about money for them.
Money, money, money.
What about the future of our town?
We all have to make sacrifices for our city.
I don't understand.
Oh my god.
Not this guy.
Not our farm.
Alright, Buttercup.
At least you...
Oh my god.
No!
Oh fuck!
Oh my god.
I didn't even realize.
Why...
Why do they just want to...
Okay, we'll put 200 in here.
Oh my god.
Not the market.
They're all just here.
They're all...
Rats.
What's up?
Grosses.
Thank you for the...
Super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
That's fine.
I have woes.
If anything...
We have woes.
Okay.
Uh...
I feel like...
Okay, we gotta build another fountain.
For sure.
I'll build one here.
And then I'll build another fountain.
Wait, where's this fountain?
I'll build another fountain here.
Just in case.
So then my people can be healed.
It's okay.
The tax man is coming.
Don't worry.
Everyone.
The tax man is here.
That's right.
Tax them all.
Oh my god.
I'll look at Wally.
I'll watch him slowly die.
I don't have to waste money on people.
Okay.
Explore this dungeon.
Put 200 in there.
Surely...
Surely people would be...
Okay.
300.
Would $300 suffice, guys?
Would $300...
Not...
Would $300 make you happy?
Excuse me?
Too small?
You were just born.
Okay.
400.
500?
550.
Oh.
Dad.
Okay.
Oh.
Of course.
Dad.
It's like...
Yippee!
Of fucking course.
You want that money.
Of course you do.
Now we're talking.
Yeah, sure.
I don't know what he does.
What is he even doing?
Oh, is he in the dungeon yet?
Alright.
Get in there.
Is that the only one that would be like...
Yeah, sure.
Yeah.
What is your...
Enlisting...
Recovering happiness and then buy a beer.
All right.
Can you go in the dungeon?
Wait, that's it!
You fucker.
You took 500...
You...
You fucking...
Oh, I should have got the rock.
I should have fucking...
I should have got the...
Go pay your goddamn fucking taxes.
Go...
I wanted you to explore in a dungeon.
What are you...
Oh, my God.
Your dad is a genius.
He's like...
Oh, I got my 550.
Guess I'll go...
I'll go buy a beer now.
I don't...
That...
That's not a call.
I can't believe he...
Oh, my God.
I can't believe he did that.
He literally just went there...
For, like, 550 and just left...
The actual fucker.
Wait, there's, like, people here.
I'm, like, literally looking into something.
Where is this monster?
Next wave power...
Is it here?
Oh, there he is.
Okay.
I'll do this.
Okay, I feel like...
Maybe...
I'll do 600.
70.
700.
How is only Lucy okay with this quest?
Already taken.
Not for a god beast.
What do you mean already taken?
Oh, my God.
Please.
Okay, it's fine.
We'll defend our land here.
And then...
Okay, good.
All right, good.
Oh, now you're willing to take $100.
But not any of this.
Okay, that's fine.
That's okay.
The rats began to swarm.
Again?
How...
Oh, my God.
How many...
Again, how many do they need?
Please, someone.
Please kill these guys.
Please.
Somebody killed him.
Rats.
We're the rats.
Wait, did I...
Made it one?
I mean, he's still alive.
Wait, did he just left?
All right.
All right, guys.
Come on.
Surely, let's not leave it up for just the...
Come on, guys.
Let's not leave it up just for two goblins, guys.
Guys, I feel like if it was just two goblins, we might be fucked.
What if I just send the wolves in here?
Oh.
I just accidentally sent more things to fight this.
I...
Never mind.
I think the wolves was a bad idea.
Maybe.
The wolves may or may not have been a bad idea.
All right.
Let's get rid of him.
I'll just look at him.
I'll help.
Don't worry.
Oh, wait.
This...
This guy does nothing.
Oh!
Okay, he's fine.
It does nothing.
It's literally just like...
It's...
Remember that wolf I accidentally...
I paid money for?
Uh...
Whoops.
I should not have paid money for that wolf.
All right, yeah.
He's just standing there.
Yeah, I thought he'd do more.
Look at that.
Oh, that's so many perks.
I got rangers, though.
Let's get rangers.
Let's just add more people into our town.
You know what?
Go explore that dungeon.
Let's put all...
Let's put our best people in here.
Oh, wait.
Attack that.
More.
Oh, my God.
I was not expecting...
Wait.
Where is the wave coming from?
Guys?
Guys.
Okay.
I was gonna say...
Guys.
There you are.
Like a...
Oh, there is a lot.
Oh, what is that?
There is a prison, too?
Oh, it's fine.
I'm looking at them.
I'm helping.
I'm looking.
By looking.
Don't worry, people.
Wait.
But who's gonna...
Okay.
Don't worry.
They're defending here.
I'm helping my team.
I volunteer as...
Look harder.
I'm looking as hard as I can.
Wait.
Did someone die?
Wasn't there four of them?
Wait.
Does no one want to take this?
Okay.
What if I put another $100 in here?
And $150.
$400?
That's fine.
$400 should be enough.
Alright.
Good job, Doki.
Good job.
You looked at them.
See, guys?
I looked.
The ranger.
And then...
We'll add another...
We'll add another ranger here.
I have one more here, too.
And then...
Doki throwing money at the problem.
Don't worry.
I believe.
Come on, guys.
Wait.
Can you guys not attack this?
Are you guys scared?
What are you guys scared about?
Come on.
See...
I'll put another $100 in there.
Why are you so scared?
Just fight it.
You're so...
You're so healthy.
Yeah, that's right.
Don't worry.
I'll look at it.
Help out.
What is over...
There's like...
Oh, shit.
Okay, wait.
I thought that was a destroyed thing.
Yes.
Money will solve all problems.
Oh, wait.
I got more perks.
Let's go.
Oh, that's a chance to hit twice.
Collect.
But your gold...
Your units regenerate faster when you're looking.
Oh, my God.
I can regenerate them, too.
Don't worry, guys.
I shall keep looking.
The health care is $600 at least.
Look.
You guys don't want...
Oh, my God.
What the fuck is that?
Hey, there's...
There's...
What is that over there?
Was that the prison home that I destroyed?
No.
This was the prison home.
Okay, let's just kill these guys.
I don't know what they are, but...
Just fuck them up.
Yeah, that's a lot.
Don't worry.
They'll be fine.
I'll start looking.
Look.
Okay, I'll have a list.
200.
300.
There we go.
Oh, now it's attractive.
Oh, now you guys liked it.
Look at that.
Wait.
What happened to him?
Who is she?
Oh, my God.
Is that the ranger?
Oh, it is.
I was like, are she okay?
I was like, what is that?
Is she okay?
Holy fuck.
I don't know, but she's pretty hot.
Okay, let's see.
How about that?
300?
400?
500?
All right.
500 is what they want.
I believe in them.
As long as I...
Oh, she's like, I'm not taking that.
She saw...
They saw, like...
They're just like, yeah, no.
Yeah.
They saw how many people there.
Okay, how about 600?
650.
Yes.
Come on, guys.
Look, I'm literally helping.
I'm helping so much.
How did you guys back out?
There you go.
Look.
All right.
Guys, come on.
They're literally right there.
They're literally...
Look, you have an army of cow women.
Come on.
Look at...
Okay.
All right.
Oh, she's sinking.
They're almost dead.
By the time they get there, they're almost dead.
We explored it and it's not worth it.
Please.
All right.
What about...
750.
7% attractiveness now.
Okay.
850.
My final offer.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
We gotta defend this real quick.
Please.
We gotta save the ranger.
Oh, wait.
Cool.
Wait.
We have the beast tamer too?
How many?
Wait.
What?
Okay.
I know, like...
There's, like, a lot of stuff going on.
Goth unrelenting.
Goth huntress.
Wait.
There's so much more here.
Okay.
Wait.
Someone defend.
All right.
All the...
They all came back for this.
They all...
They're like, we're not fighting this.
But, like...
We'll deal with the others.
All right.
Fine.
I'll slowly watch them until they die.
Wait.
Unless...
Okay.
We gotta rebuild this, though.
That's fine.
Uh...
Let's build, like, an inn next to it, too.
All right.
We'll build an inn next to here.
And a fountain?
We have a fountain here?
Oh, we do.
That's fine.
Nobody wants to take this mission.
So, I'll do the mission myself.
Oh.
Why are y'all leaving?
I gave so much money.
Okay.
9.50.
My final offer.
That's my final offer.
It's not even that bad.
It's...
Fine.
I'll look at them myself.
Okay.
1K.
1...
Oh.
Now you want to come over just because they're all slowly dying.
Yeah.
I don't know.
This looks like a scam.
How is this a scam?
I'm literally giving them free money right now.
I'm doing most of the work at this point.
Oh, my God.
I'm just doing most of the work at this point.
I swear to God.
They're all just like, is she done yet?
Is she done yet so I can take my free money?
Hey, you fuckers.
Is she...
Oh, yeah.
Yes.
What did I get out of that?
When faced with death, headchance turns the blood of dying creatures into gold?
That sounds...
I don't know what that is, but that sounds fucking hardcore.
Eliminate Bobmaster.
Is this Bobmaster?
Are they still just like...
Like, what am I looking at?
Wait.
Are you serious?
Because I...
I swear to God.
Did they claim my money?
Did they...
Did they claim it?
Oh, my God.
I...
It's because I did all the work that they...
Oh.
Oh, my...
It's fine.
I'm fine.
I am fine.
I am...
I'm fine.
It's fine.
We'll just...
We don't need it.
What are they called?
Like, the people you outsource...
Like, the merc...
We don't need these fucking mercenaries.
We...
We'll build our own defenses.
We don't need these mercenaries.
We have the tower.
What is this?
All units dying in it generates gold.
But, like, are they my units still?
Like, I...
Are they my units that generate it?
Or, like, the end...
My contract is...
Yeah.
Here.
Here's another 100.
Why are you so scared?
They're level 1!
I don't...
Why are you so scared?
They're literally...
They're level 1.
Who's gonna hurt you?
We're turning the cowgirls into gold.
The rats will do it for some cheese.
Just saying.
I'm just saying.
Who's gonna hurt you?
They're level 1!
Okay.
We...
Oh, I forgot to build the...
Laboratory.
I don't know what the Laboratory does.
But let's just build it for the sake of it.
Okay.
They're all defending it here.
I'll just...
I'll keep looking.
Eventually, they'll die, right?
Eventually.
Look at all the people that was like, I don't want to do this mission.
Okay.
Not gonna lie.
This game is very addicting.
By the way.
If you guys forgot, I am sponsored to play it.
But this game is actually pretty addicting.
So, if you guys want to check it out yourself, you can actually download the game.
Buy and download the game right now.
Oh, hey.
There's Dilbert.
Maybe the wolves will do it.
Something.
Maybe?
Okay.
At least the wolves.
Look at that!
The wolves!
Oh, my God.
I paid $500 for the wolves.
Look at that.
See?
Look at...
Oh, my God.
They died instantly.
Okay.
Maybe I can tell...
I think there's a reason why they did not want to fight these guys.
Oh, my God.
They actually just died instantly.
Oh, man.
Maybe they were right.
Okay.
We'll delete that.
Yeah.
I think I now know why they did not want to do anything with them.
I understand now.
I sort of understand.
Maybe there was...
They were high to something.
Holy shit.
How far does it...
Oh, my God.
There's more over here.
I don't know if you guys noticed this, but there's more over here.
Okay.
Uh...
All right.
Oh, my gosh.
I'll open my chest here.
Your gold vent.
When faced with adventures, I have a chance.
When faced with death.
It's the same thing.
Okay.
I guess that's fine.
Increases this thing, though.
How big?
Yeah.
I looked at it.
I was like, okay, that guy's pretty fucking big.
I'm not a dealer.
Where's my lab?
I built a lab here.
I don't know what this lab does.
Oh, I guess it does strength potions.
Can I even...
Oh, it's for my adventures.
My adventures...
My mercenaries, contractors spend money in my city.
So I can gain the money back.
Oh, my God.
That's so smart.
If I build more of these, they'll spend more money in my city.
Oh, my God.
Not the rats.
Not the fucking rats.
Did I not build...
Oh, my God.
It's your con.
Okay, wait.
I'll build like a little...
Did they just run past my defense tower?
Oh, it's because they came from that sewer.
The free money glitch.
Yeah, I was thinking.
I was like, they'll spend money in my city with the money I paid them.
That's so smart.
Alright, guys.
Okay.
I have to...
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, I might play this more off stream.
Because like, this is actually pretty...
Pretty addicting.
But...
I have to stop.
Because I have a lot to do later.
But that was fun, though.
That was really, really...
Because I have to prep for my next stream.
But that was really, really fun.
I hope that you guys...
Uh, you guys enjoyed...
Uh, today's stream, guys.
Um, a huge shout out to...
Uh, oh, my gosh.
No.
I paused.
I...
Wait, I just realized I couldn't...
I didn't even fast forward this.
I was playing everything in slow motion.
Okay, wait.
Maybe...
I want to see if this...
I want to see, like...
Dad, why are you just looking at them?
Dad, please.
Dad, please help out.
Oh, my God.
I wanted to see if this works.
But it didn't matter.
Because...
I didn't realize...
I forgot to fast forward this game.
I was playing at 1x.
But even then, it felt fast enough.
At 1x.
Um...
But anyway...
You guys want to...
You guys want to check out this game?
Um...
You can do so...
By clicking the link pinned in my chat.
And in my description.
Um...
It was very interesting.
Because, like...
When they, like...
Uh...
Approached us.
They were actually...
Like...
They were actually thinking about adding dragoons in here, too.
In the future.
I don't know if it will happen.
But if they do...
That would be really cool.
Um...
And I would love to play the game again.
When the dragoons are added.
Um...
But I'm not sure...
I'm not sure, like...
If it will happen, though.
Um...
But it was, like, fun.
I haven't played a...
Uh...
RTS in a while.
Um...
So it was really fun.
Uh...
Controlling my min...
Little...
My little men and cow women.
Um...
Uh...
But yeah.
Thank you again for...
Thank you again for the sponsor.
Um...
And...
Uh...
I hope you guys enjoyed watching.
Um...
It really did not feel like a sponsor.
I was...
I got, like, way into it.
Um...
I got...
Let's give, like, Dad...
One last...
Escaping!
What the fuck?
No!
You are not...
Escaping!
They're like...
She's ending it!
It's time that I can finally leave the city!
Dad!
What?
I'm like, I was...
There's two options for them to escape!
Like...
What the fuck?
What?
The fact there's two options...
They're like, yeah!
Time to seek our freedom!
He wants...
Like, both!
There's two options where, like...
I...
Plan A, escape!
Plan B, escape!
Game!
Again!
And...
Anyway, guys...
Anyway...
Um...
What the fuck is Dad doing?
I hope you guys had a fun time watching.
I had a fun time playing.
Um...
And like I said, please check out the game.
It really will help out the chat a lot.
And, you know...
Maybe we'll get Dragoons later on in the line, too.
Um...
But yeah, everyone...
We do have another stream later today.
Uh...
With...
With Ramen.
Um...
It is a very interesting stream concept.
I actually don't know what's gonna happen.
Because they planned the stream out.
Um...
But it has something to do with 10 microwaves, apparently.
But anyway, guys...
I'll see you...
I'll rate that stream later, too.
As always, everybody...
Stay hydrated.
Pause to check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you...
Say up for me...
Head to bed!
Because...
You deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time, everybody!
Bye, guys!
Bye!